So now that we know how to simplify terms,
we can get back to Grant and his gleaming
glasses. Earlier, we came up with
expressions for the amount of money that
Grant's going to make from his friends
buying his wipers, and also from them
buying his nozzles, and we had an equation
for the total amount of money earned.
Saying that the total amount of money
he's going to earn from his friends is
equal to the amount that they spent on his
wipers plus the amount that they spent on
his nozzles. Now I'm going to add one more
equation into the mix for you or rather
create one more variable. Total money
earned right here takes a long time to
write, so instead I'm going to call this a
different variable. Let's say a. So, with
my other equations up here, I can also
write total money earned euals a.
So let's combine all this information that we
came up with in our earlier quizzes and
the new information that I just gave you
that a stands for the total amount of
money earned. Which of these expressions
down here, do you think should replace
this question mark, in this equation for
a? You can check as many answers as you
think are right. I know this is a lot to
look at on the screen at one time, but
once we come up with this final equation,
we'll only have single letters and
numbers, and no more words, in our
equation, and that will make things much
easier for the future.